and again just told me it's handed it it
is clear now that care homes and their
vulnerable residents have paid a heavy
price in this crisis okay
debts quadrupled in one week leading up
to April attend tests now for frontline
staff are key to this fight and the
health secretary Matt Hancock said more
tests were being carried out it's
terrific that we have managed to
increase the capacity to over 39,000
tests a day which is higher than our
planned trajectory of course having
excess capacity means that we can then
expand who that capacity can be used by
but that's not the full story tests the
social care workers are limited to a few
sites around the country and no one
seems to know how many tests have been
carried out to try to discover how
widespread tests the social care workers
have been in the last week we asked the
Department of Health public health
England and the Care Quality Commission
for exact numbers of tests carried out
in the last seven days we haven't been
given an answer to that and so we asked
the national care forum to ask their
members on behalf of Sky News of those
who had tests booked in only a quarter
were able to get to them and the average
round-trip to get to a test was 60 miles
Chloe Butler is a care of suffering
covered 19 symptoms to get to her local
test centre would mean a 140 mile
round-trip David Ramage is Chloe's boss
and says the tests are too far away if
they don't have anybody to drive them to
there then they're there they can't
access a test so potentially 33 and my
staff couldn't access a test anyway even
if I requested a one for them
care homes are now a month into this
crisis and here at Sheffield they're
trying to find care and nursing staff to
replace those of work I think we're just
reacting daily weekly to the issues that
were being faced with and I think it's
really important that you know it's
recognized what we're doing and the
support that's needed and that it gets
to the frontline service
I think lessons need to be learned from
this the national care forum says
providers are anxious many say that test
results are coming back too slowly and
the guidance is muddled and often
confusing driving centers are not
necessarily ideal for people working in
a distributed system like the care
sector with piloting a number of
different ways of getting tests out to
people both directly sending swabs to
care homes also the secretary mentioned
testing at home and also mobile delivery
coronavirus and care homes has proved a
lethal combination tests remain key if
care homes are to cope Nick Martin Sky
News Sheffield